Nos preguntan, ¿cuáles de las siguientes
rectas son perpendiculares?
Y aquí tenemos tres rectas de las cuales dos  de estas tres rectas deben ser perpendiculares entre sí,
pues no se puede ser perpendicular a sí misma.
Y bueno, si hablamos de rectas perpendiculares
y para que visualices mejor como se ven,
rectas perpendiculares, dos rectas son perpendiculares
si se intersectan en ángulos rectos.
Si ésta que trazo aquí es una de las rectas,
entonces, una recta perpendicular se va a ver así,
ésta va a ser una recta perpendicular
porque va a intersectar a la otra pero no
en cualquier intersección, va a intersecta
a la otra en ángulos rectos,
en una intersección muy especial.
Ahora, si dos rectas son perpendiculares y
voy a decir que la pendiente de esta recta
rojiza es "m", con esto vamos a decir que
su ecuación es "y" igual a "mx" más... ehhh...
y vamos a decir un tal "b1", una intersección
con el eje de las "y".
Entonces la ecuación que está de la recta
de amarillo,
su pendiente va a ser el inverso negativo de este cuate.
Por lo tanto, el inverso multiplicativo es
1 entre "m" y negativo,
por lo tanto,  la ecuación de esta recta de amarillo va a ser "y" igual a -1/m, todo esto por "x",
más otra intersección con el eje de las "y".
Y bueno, otra forma de verlo sería decir
que si dos rectas son perpendiculares,
entonces el producto de sus pendientes es igual a -1.
Así que vamos a escribirlo, esto es muy importante,
"m" por -1 entre "m", esto va a ser...
estos dos cuates se van a cancelar..
entonces me va a quedar, -1.
Así que regresando al problema, vamos a encontrar
las pendientes de estas rectas y vamos a ver
si alguna de ellas cumple que su pendiente
sea la inversa negativa de alguna de las demás.
En la recta A, aquí está muy fácil porque
ya está la forma pendiente ordenada al origen,
por lo tanto sabemos que su pendiente es igual a 3.
Es decir, a esta recta ya no hay que modificarle nada
porque sabemos que su pendiente "m" es igual a 3.
Ahora vamos a fijarnos qué es lo que pasa
con la recta B y con la recta C.
La recta B, no está en la forma pendiente
ordenada al origen,
así que vamos a despejar "y" para obtener así la pendiente de esta recta.
Y para despejar a "y" primero tenemos, "x"
más "3y" esto es igual a -21.
De aquí vamos a partir y lo que voy a hacer
es restar "x" de ambos lados de la ecuación.
Así que menos "x" de este lado y de este
otro lado también menos "x".
Y ahora, "x" y "-x", estos dos se van, es
justo lo que yo quiero.
Y me va a quedar, "3y" es igual a "-x" menos
21... a "-x" menos 21.
Y ahora, para despejar a "y", lo que voy a
hacer es dividir todo entre 3,
tanto el lado izquierdo como el lado derecho, de tal manera que estos dos se van a cancelar y del lado
izquierdo solamente me queda "y", mientras
que del lado derecho me queda -1/3 de "x"
menos 21 entre 3, lo cual es 7.
Y ya con esto, podemos ver que la pendiente
de esta recta es igual a -1/3.
Y vamos a apuntarlo, la pendiente de la recta
B es igual a -1/3.
Y ahora... ¡wow!, fíjate que estas dos pendientes
son inversas negativas, la una de la otra.
Si tú tomas el inverso multiplicativo de
3, es 1/3 y éste es el negativo de ese mismo.
O si tú tomas el inverso multiplicativo de -1/3 es menos -3 y aquí tenemos el negativo de ese mismo.
Y ¡wow! esto está de lujo, porque ahora podemos decir
que estas dos rectas en definitiva
son dos rectas perpendiculares... perpendiculares.
Ahora vamos a ver qué es lo que pasa con la recta C.
Si te das cuenta, la recta C tampoco está
en la forma pendiente ordenada al origen,
por lo tanto, vamos a despejar a "y" de esta ecuación.
Y tengo, "3x" más "y" es igual a 10 y para
despejar a "y" lo que voy a hacer es restar
"3x" de ambos lados de la ecuación, de tal
manera que del lado izquierdo estos dos se
van a cancelar y me queda simple y sencillamente
que "y" es igual a "-3x" más 10.
Y ya con esto, encontramos la pendiente.
La pendiente de la recta C es igual a -3 y
date cuenta que esta pendiente
es la negativa de esta otra pendiente, sin embargo,
no es el inverso multiplicativo.
Por otra parte, esta pendiente es el inverso
multiplicativo de esta otra, de la recta B,
sin embargo no es negativa, no cumplen con
que una es negativa y la otra es positiva.
Por lo tanto, mi respuesta es que la recta
A y la recta B son perpendiculares.